what's up reject nation the mandalorian
season two episode five all i know is
dave filoni directed this
and ahsoka tano finally appears it's
impossible to avoid that information if
you have a twitter account can't wait to
see what's in store
guys if you end up enjoying this video
please hit that like button subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is
up also gotta thank eric over at nerd
chronic for editing this video for us he
works his butt off to make sure these
videos can get visible
on youtube so thank you so much eric for
all the hard work full-length reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code are available over at our
patreon page where over there we cover
so many shows we're at the same tier you
get the option for watch along or
reaction highlights included thank you
guys so much for all the support you've
shown us this month hopefully you had a
great holiday yesterday let's finally
watch this
[Music]
the moment we've all been waiting for
very cool
very nice
oh is that michael bean
she is like one of the best characters
ever from star wars
wow what an intro
so pov
oh it's so cool
damn dad she looks exactly like her
surrender
or face the consequences you have one
day
to decide
it's like game of thrones i love every
time her lightsabers disappear she
disappears into the shadows the miss and
she's like this imposing predator
hunting force
yeah yeah the jedi
what did i say about that
not much to see out here there's a
soaker
[Laughter]
i just remember that felony directed
episode five of the first season too
it's like the t-800
[Music]
it's like a horror nice maze yeah
i have a proposition that may interest
you
a jedi plagues me i want you to kill her
[Laughter]
that's the spear that took down smog
pull it right out of his heart
no way pure best scar
no way kill the jedi
and it's yours this guy has to do so
many missions for just information all
the time
yeah he gets to kill two birds with one
stone he gets the best card speeder
and he gets to find a sokata yeah
[Music]
isn't the medicine music so good in this
yeah it's just like a
shriek it's just like a primordial
shriek
is that mori i saw an owl there
yeah a false alarm
[Music]
i hope it's about him
are they force communicating right now
that's the sense i'm getting yeah
is he speaking do you
understand him grogo and i can feel each
other's thoughts grogu
grogu yes
we learned his name oh my god this is no
longer baby yoda
grogu what an interesting name
he was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant no way
you've trained him over the years what
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power
he was hidden oh damn
then his memory becomes dark
oh [ __ ] we've heard it so much
i've only known one other being like
this a wise jedi master named
can he still wield the force it is an
energy field
created by all living things take them
to mortis now
that's crazy tying that into order 66
that was that was nuts
did not expect to look at any of that
information
wonder what denjarin's face looks like
under the helmet right now
oh my buddy
lift the stone kroger
[Music]
sounds like greg
gregoo if you got married to a roku
grogu
do you want this come on you got this
little guy
yeah good job cue that mandolin
his attachment to you makes him
vulnerable to his fears
i've seen what such feelings can do to a
fully trained job oh
yeah to the best of us oh yeah oh she's
totally talking about him
and i'll help you with your problem if
you see to it that grogu
is properly trained soca were to train
grogan that'd be
crazy a mandalorian and a jedi
cool i'll never see it coming
i love the samurai western vibe they've
infused in this one
oh my god get up there
yes
damn she's awesome
we got the swinging lanterns
oh nice
your bouncy hunter failed clever
where is your master
the crying out loud who is it who's the
master
[Music]
execute them then go door to door
damn she is cold
yes
[Laughter]
yes
oh
nice nice
[Music]
looks that way
it's cool how they captured ahsoka from
other people's perspectives
oh yeah building up the mystique in
anticipation
[Music]
who do you think's gonna win
[Music]
dude the sound design yeah
there we go
oh no yeah she'll be fine
you got the the western fight and then
the samurai fight yeah the two
influences of star wars yeah
oh so great i love that
[Music]
booyah sounds like you win
don't try to pull a fast one on it yeah
don't try to pull a fast one on and pull
some [ __ ]
don't do it man i like you michael bean
come on michael being get you i like you
michael bean
allow yourself to return god damn it oh
damn it they are honoring western movies
look man
behind you
where is grand admiral thrawn
we're gonna see thrawn in this show i
believe this
was your payment oh there's so much
information
i didn't finish the job but this belongs
with a mandalorian
yeah man plus like you know the people
who originally hired you
are not in power anymore where's your
little friend
oh [ __ ] wait here i'll go get him
i feel like we're setting up for an
ahsoka tano spin-off series i could see
that
for certain and that's where you're
seeing her hunt thrawn
[Music]
or should i say grogan greg goop
he's gregory now
i feel like maf gideon's going to show
up some yeah
something no you're like
[Laughter]
go to the planet tython place kroger on
the seeing stone at the top of the
mountain
then what if he reaches out through the
force there's a chance a jedi may sense
his presence
and come searching for him which
which one get mace
may the force be with you
there's a cow
oh it's so good
the music is so good in this episode
it's always
good that was great fantastic that was
great
oh he wrote it too i didn't expect
nothing less i got missed yet at the end
of this [ __ ] man ugh okay so
at the end of rebels ezra bridger
disappeared
some unknown place and with thrawn on
the ship throwing his batty
okay is she looking for thrawn this in
hopes she could find ezra bridger
we haven't even brought him up yet but
the last time we saw him was with
ron at the end of rebels so uh i could
definitely see them doing something like
or because using the hope of that
possibility
i haven't read any books or anything so
i don't thrawn's like established that
he's already alive but you know their
fates were kind of unknown
at the end of rebels but then you learn
all the stuff about freaking
grogu and then after order 66 happened
someone got him out of there maybe
maybe it was yoda i mean maybe his mace
windu if he is alive i'm still
hoping that theory holds true talking
about other jedi the only uh
there's like luke skywalker who's alive
there's cal from fallen order
it could be cool i mean get him on the
show
i mean the character cameron monahan's
an amazing actor and when he's in the
game they
did his likeness to him so he could pull
off a live-action version it would be
so freaking awesome yeah to watch you
know a younger
jedi or you know at this point you know
a little bit older but you know take on
that mantle of master
in such like a huge i don't know there's
so many ways you can go with it that all
sound cool
let's talk about it all right so this is
probably going to be a bit of a thick
discussion
let's try to keep it as focused as
possible i loved it i thought it was
pretty
near perfect you know you get the blends
of both the samurai world
and the western influences all combined
into one
i mean this was like out of all the
episodes we've gotten it
would appear that this is the most asian
influenced one
that has been the most apparent in
drawing from there
i thought dave filoni knocked it out of
the park it's amusing to me how
chapter five of the first season you
know some people thought that that was
like the weakest episode and this
quickly makes it as like one of the top
episodes for me and i love how you have
ahsoka in
clone wars and then for rebels just to
be transparent
i haven't seen all of rebels all i did
in order because i saw clone wars that i
was like oh man but i need to get some
rebels in there to know more of ahsoka's
journey leading into mandalorian looked
up
all the necessary essential episodes
that linked to mandalore
and ahsoka tano and had to watch those
so i watched those i was able to get
like plenty of information or to follow
what was happening here and it's cool
how
she's a character who grows a lot in
clone wars
and she becomes easily my favorite
character in that series
she's reinvented as more mature version
in rebels and then here she's even a
little bit more reinvented as well
allowing rosario dawson to provide her
own fresh
spin and take on her because ahsoka tano
i
feel like usually has a little bit more
fun with her personality
this seemed to be a lot more of a
reserved performance
versus what ahsoka tano is kind of like
in the animated series where she's a
little bit more
expressive and perhaps a little bit more
relatable in the way she talks about
things and here she's a much more like
solo
lorn warrior hunter jedi but it still
felt like ahsoka tano to me so i like
you get
three different versions of her the
clone wars version the rebels version
and now
because she's maturing she's growing
older you know and she's had several
adventures since
we last saw her in rebels as well a lot
of different experiences that have
changed her and i thought for the most
part rosario dawson did a wonderful job
and it's different but still feels like
no ahsoka could have grown
into this individual judge what'd you
think of sokatan
yeah no i mean obviously i don't have as
much experience with this character as
you do though i have seen glimpses
and what i really loved about this is
the mandalorian is a show where
often times yeah you might see a
character for one episode and it's sort
of on the actor to bring
a whole lot of presence and life to a
character and so like going off what i
knew about her but also knowing that
this is a bit in the future
i thought rosario dawson brought a ton
of presents and poise
to the character that you know i i feel
like this is a character that can easily
kind of fly by is just like ah she's
here and that's kind of enough she's the
kind of character who could fly by based
on presence alone
and also being that she is not quite as
expressive in this episode a lot is
played in her face and body language
some could argue that you know
you need a lot of presence to achieve
that and for me i thought she knocked
that out of the park i really felt
the presence of a character who clearly
exists well beyond this episode and i
felt like the intro really did a nice
job of just
physically driving that home making her
such a presence and throughout the
episode using
some horror-esque techniques of yeah
showing
most of the action from the people in
the city's perspective you know the
different droids and soldiers
perspective and then
seeing that side of her along with you
know the moments where she is in the
woods communicating with baby yoda with
grogu
we now know his name is grogan those
moments that whole scene where they're
communicating back and forth they're not
saying anything i i loved the
expressions
and the amount of just yeah rich i don't
know i got a really
rich sort of emotional impact from that
scene all without any dialogue so yeah
all suffice to say that she's terrific
in my eyes and i thought that this
episode was really strong just across
the board yeah i mean she brought that
wisdom to life yeah and she
also had the size where you do see the
compassionate
connective layers to her but then yeah
also like at the very beg
first off i was surprised that we see
her right away
i thought it was gonna be like halfway
through the episode she have some like
big show
up superhero landing moment or something
you know i thought it was gonna be
something more along those lines so for
dave filoni to bring her
into here right away where you do get
more of this
lethal warrior presence and she is kind
of spooky
from the perspective of others i thought
was really awesome
i mean i could kind of go on and on
about ahsoka being in here because
she is one of the best characters in
star wars period well that's indicative
of something i really appreciated about
this episode twofold is
is not really wasting any time getting
to her and the second she and
dinjarin cross paths a lot of shows
might have played that whole
thing out longer for action or something
and i love that they get right to the
point in that scene too
hey i was sent here by bo katan and then
later on he reveals the other part with
the magistrate but like every
opportunity for like a time-wasting
squabble i thought was
surpassed in honor of storytelling yeah
i mean just seeing her with the dual
lightsabers brought to life i mean even
that one shot
where she at the in the finale battle
kind of reminded me of the
famous shot where she fights vader in
rebels the shh
this really close-up one you know you
could really feel that i wonder if i
think dave felony and i directed that
episode too i'm not sure either way man
i think that
this episode just kind of proves to me
that dave filoni ought to be in charge
of the star wars movies
i think he should like he brought a
different layer than what he brought in
season one the menacing undertones
throughout
the gloom and doom vibe but also really
honoring
the themes of hope heroism and of course
the traditional influences that sprung
up star wars
way back in the 70s when lucas first
started this right and then of course
like the information with the
the magistrate having heard like ahsoka
fighter and you know like there was this
part of me that was
watching them fight thinking like ahsoka
could probably take this woman out
easily but she needs the information and
that just
springs open a whole door of of
questions right
i really am more under the impression
that we've heard rumors about an ahsoka
tano spin-off i wouldn't be surprised if
this is more where it's going because
that's a whole other thing you gotta
unpack that i'm not sure how you would
seamlessly
flow that into this series when you've
already got
a whole new can of worms open here
learning about
grogu and i'm just trying to get used to
that
trying to use that name grogu learning
about grogu and i love how
casually they reveal that information
she just says his name and how he was
born in the jedi i wonder if he was born
around the time anakin skywalker was
born but even the information that's
revealed there of why she specifically
won't train him
and it makes me wonder if the title of
the jedi is easy to kind of go oh is
that to ahsokatan but
i wonder if it's actually linked to
grogu versus her quick recap on the
information that was learned grew up in
coruscant part of the jedi temple
order 66 happened somebody got him out
of there
and then had to have his memory go dark
in order to protect him
it's kind of like in doctor who when
they have the doctor a time lord go
human so that way other people can't
detect he's a time lord
but she won't train him and it sounds
like the dialogue that she was at least
given was talking about anakin skywalker
because of his attachments for padme
wanting to save her is what led him down
the dark side and jedi are not supposed
to have these attachments
the attachment towards denjarin that
grogu has
could be a thing that leads him down the
ultimate side of the dark side right i
guess that's what the ultimate fear is
of why ahsoka won't do it but then also
setting up
that is tython is what the pla that
planet is
that temple is called i don't think it's
that place in rebels where ahsoka
and anakin fought each other that's
brought to ruins
so well maybe that one special seeing
stone is still there
but let me know down below which what it
is i'm sure there's people out there who
who know what that planet is if it is a
stop because like corvus from my
understanding is a new planet please do
let me know i'm always always curious to
learn more it's setting up that another
jedi has to show up
it's very likely it could be luke
skywalker but this could also be leading
down the path
where he has to let grow goo go which is
uh heartbreaking in a lot of ways
especially after seeing the bond that is
really
even further established in this episode
yeah it's like the
is becoming the heart of the show is
their
interplay yeah the magistrate character
she was cool
i i wish michael bean had a little just
because
of a biased love for michael bean
we just had a character that really like
made him shine it felt like he was just
there that day
yeah he was like a fun character it was
fun because especially if you have a
love for michael bean that's the part i
was like i wish he had a little bit more
to do or was able to at least
maybe he is alive you know in star wars
a lot of these characters survive when
you
you think they're dead you know it was
still fun seeing him show up here
yeah and uh the magistrate character was
cool yeah this this episode i thought
was pretty rock solid especially in the
sound design too
sounded music the way the composition of
dave filoni shots
was very impressive i feel like he got
his feet wet in chapter five with live
action for star wars and then here
he just showed supreme directing skills
working with the cinematographer on this
episode and also the writing i thought
was
really good too i do wonder though
because if i hadn't been
educating myself with so many things
leading up to the season two of
mandalorian
there's so much i would be wildly lost
on and there's still things i don't know
you know i'm like what is tython
i'm not familiar with that is there
something in the books or games that
establish
that thrawn is in fact still alive and
has been doing things on the side after
the battle of endor for people who
haven't
dived into that this more than the bokeh
tan episode
seems to really rely on you having seen
stuff like clone wars and rebels or at
least watching videos or breakdowns of
it in order to
really understand a lot of what's
happening here well i think they have a
smart
aspect of this where even just
introducing those like if people
are invested in this show and at least
are invested in the movies i feel like
any name they drop now is kind of
inspiration for people to
at least go online and look it up and
see i feel like they are laced in a lot
of gateways to the other media
because i don't have as much experience
with it as you do i mean i didn't leave
this episode feeling confused or
anything i was more like okay i got a
couple
names to remember of who i should look
out for what places we might go well i'm
saying that
ahsoka the whole time is is uh targeting
the magistrate she needs to learn
information you're like i want to know
where your master is i want to know
where your master is and then she names
drops thrawn
which is huge but you know
a lot of people who haven't seen people
won't know who that is you know
i think it's partially the benefit too
of this show's structure
because you're constantly learning one
thing and then getting used to the idea
that it's gonna be a while before i see
that
yeah there's gonna be a bunch of side
quests intermittently and i think that
maybe cuts down on some of that yeah and
i also want to
shout out the fact of honoring more of
that western flair too
the city ruins and you know it's being
controlled by these
terrible people michael bean is kind of
like the bad
sheriff in town he's got those scruples
yeah who's who's ruled by
the magistrate who's who's like the
person with money and power
you know yeah so you have that and i l
and i love the juxtaposition because
when you're
with magistrate it feels straight out of
like a kung fu film
yeah or a samurai movie i love how how
much it took its time with its pacing
whenever you were with anything that was
jedi related
to some extent yeah this had a really
great sense of pace and tone and i just
personally love that no matter where we
went on this place everything
even the nicest part of this planet was
janky yeah this is like the worst planet
in the star wars universe and also you
know like there's been a lot of things
that we've touched on with how
uh dinjarin has had to learn to kind of
go against his
whatever he thought it meant to be a
mandalorian here and then you even have
that ending button right here with
accepting the best car steal
of the spear and season one i don't
think he would have accepted it yeah
and then here in season two you know he
changes his like every episode has kind
of lent itself to something along those
lines yes
maybe not so much the the most previous
episode to this one
but the other ones for sure have touched
on something like that what i loved
about it was as much as so katana stole
the show whenever she was on screen it
still kept it focused on who its main
characters
are it didn't make you go i only want to
see ahsoka tano you know that this had
you still care
about the immediate journey that we're
supposed to be the most invested in i
bet you mafia dean is going to show up
oh he's got at that pla at that template
that he's going to show up there oh he's
snapped but yeah no that just that that
little crack about like jedi and
mandalorian working together they'll
never see it coming like that was
kind of the heart of that for me well
yeah i mean that's really especially to
have that line thrown in there
with ahsoka tano so much of the siege of
mandalore of the
being able to conquer that large part
wasn't thanks to ahsoka
a jedi teaming up with boca tan
mandalori you know and then also like
the adventures that she has had in
rebels with
working alongside mandalorian it just
it's really cool
no matter where you are in the world
it's pretty sweet
all right guys so what did you think of
this episode were you satisfied
with the interpretation rosario dawson
brought to life
for ahsoka tano and that's what
everyone's talking about so
you know leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell thank you so much for
watching hit that like button thank you
eric and
chronic last but not least
raj krishnan hey buddy thank you so much
for being part of our patreon page for
so long for just being who you are i
literally just want to take this week
which is the celebration of thanksgiving
to just give you a very sincere thank
you you have been
with us through every up and down of
whatever we've had with this channel or
patreon the entire time no matter what
we switch around or whatever direction
we want to take you've always been
supportive
like a mother effort in every which way
and are constantly contributing
with things to enhance our experiences
or to
get more educated especially in terms of
music yeah so
i really appreciate all the input you've
ever given and
the the loyalty you have shown to us has
just been
impeccable so thank you so much for
being you man i really don't know what
else to say other than the
most sincere thank you because you've
been 100 incredible to us
incredible yeah and you have such a
thoughtful wonderful spirit and it's
really nice to
have that energy directed our way so
keep on sharing man
thank you brother love you talk with you
[Music]
soon